there is growing backlash against a San
Francisco woman who allegedly called
police on an eight-year-old black girl
for selling water Jordan Rogers was
confronted by Allison Edel who was white
for not having a permit to sell bottled
water on the sidewalk the little girl's
mother intervened and recorded the
interaction on video DeMarco Morgan is
here with why critics are calling Edel a
racist today
DeMarco good morning y'all good morning
to you the young girl was selling water
because she wanted to go on her first
ever trip to Disneyland
well her mother says she is not sure if
race was a factor for the woman who
reported it but said that woman was
filled with hate for calling the police
on such a young girl so I was selling
water right Jordan Rogers was selling
water bottles on the sidewalk for about
15 minutes when she says Allison IDO
confronted her and I didn't know what a
prayer it was this woman don't want to
let a little girl sell some water rogers
immediately called for her mother
Erin Austin hide all you want the whole
world don't see you boo the incident is
the latest high-profile instance of
black people being reported to
authorities for seemingly normal things
Allison arrow now nicknamed hermit paddy
by critics has drawn comparisons to
Jennifer's show in April showed called
to the police on a group of black people
having a barbeque in a park last month a
Gail grad student called police on a
classmate for napping in a common area
and two months ago two men were detained
for use in a Starbucks bathroom and
sitting at a table for several minutes
without ordering at all told The
Huffington Post that she acted because
Rogers and her mother were screaming but
that after watching the video she feels
horrible and heart wrenched she also
said I completely regret that I handled
that so poorly
it was completely stress-related and I
should have never confronted her that
was a mistake
a complete mistake Austin denies
screaming and says the situation should
have never escalated to calling the
police let kids be kids that they're not
hurting anybody who cares
now Austin's daughter says she does plan
to keep on selling water that's what the
trip to Disneyland musician Jonathan
Brennan saw the story and has already
paid for Rogers and three of her family
members to go whenever they'd like to
but I love the part where she says you
can hide all you want but the whole
world is going to see you both Oh
world's gonna see you boo but I am glad
someone's come forward and said we'll
pay for you to go to Disney World and
let me get permit Patti the benefit of
the doubt who's now deeply regret [ __ ]
he's never apologized so let's sort of
focus on that but it's one of those
things that you just go outrageous and
this is how entrepreneurs are born yeah
you start off with lemonade stands and
brown little girls some compassion
all right DeMarco thanks you bet